mes chers compatriotes la primaire de la
droite et du centre est close les
électeurs doivent être salués pour
s'être emparé massivement et librement
de ce rendez vous démocratique
la victoire la victoire me revient et
c'est une victoire de fonds
bâti sur des convictions depuis trois
ans je trace ma route à l écoute des
français avec mon projet avec mes
valeurs et progressivement j'ai senti
cette vague qui a brisé tous les
scénarios écrits d'avancé
ma démarche a été comprise la france ne
supporte pas son décrochage
la france veut la vérité et la france
veut des actes ce quinquennat
ce quinquennat qui s'achève a été
pathétique il va falloir y mettre un
terme et repartir de l'avant comme nous
ne l'avons jamais fait depuis 30 ans
pour cela j'aurai besoin de tout le
monde et ce soir j'ai une pensée
particulière pour nicolas sarkozy
j'adresse alain juppé un message
d'amitié et d'estimé et de respect
alors
alain est un homme d'état et il le reste
aucun candidat n'a démérité cette
primaire fut digne pas un électeur ne
doit se sentir humilié ou mis à l'écart
ce qui nous unit est tellement plus
important que ce qui nous distingue
voilà pourquoi ce soir je tends la main
à tous ceux qui veulent servir notre
pays
oui
on succès mon succès je le mets en
partage je le dois à mes équipes
je le dois à mes soutiens je le dois à
tous les bénévoles qui furent admirables
de dévouement
ce succès
ce succès je le dois à ces milliers de
français que j'ai rencontré et qui m'ont
nourri de leur révolte de leurs idées de
leurs espoirs
je me suis senti porté par leur désir de
liberté et de réussite
il y a dans notre pays un immense besoin
de respect et de fierté
il ya aussi un appel à l'autorité de
l'état et à l'exemplarité de ceux qui le
dirigent les électeurs de la droite et
du centre ont trouvé dans ma démarche
les valeurs françaises auxquelles ils
sont attachés
ces valeurs
ces valeurs je les défendrai et nous les
partagerons avec tous ceux qui dans
leurs différences aime la france
personne personne ne devra se sentir
exclus d'une société que je veux plus
juste et plus solidaire
notre renaissance sera l'oeuvre de tous
elle viendra de notre volonté de nous
battre ensemble pour le bien commun et
pour que nos enfants soient heureux
d'être français je sais les défis mais
je suis portée par la confiance que fait
naître en moi cette incroyable aventure
d'un pays qui par son travail et par sa
bravoure réussi à se hisser parmi les
cinq plus grandes puissances du monde
l'avenir l'avenir nous attend et nous
avons en main tous les atouts pour être
une nation souveraine alors mais on va
continuer à écouter vide avant le
discours de françois fillon grand
vainqueur de cette primaire
j'ai maintenant le devoir de convaincre
tout un pays que notre projet est le
seul qui puisse nous hisser vers le haut
pour l'emploi pour la croissance pour la
justice
j ai confiance aux françaises et aux
français
j'en suis certain parce que je les ai
rend compte et on prête à s'élancer du
nil acheter ni résignation
je vois une force qui attend son heure
et cette force elle sera extraordinaire
si nous savons la guider vers des
changements inédit
et
j'ai celle de voir j'ai le devoir de
vaincre l'immobilisme et la démagogie
la gauche c'est l'échec l'extrême droite
c'est la faillite
je parle de vaincre ces partis
politiques
pas de vaincre ces français déçu ses
électeurs qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui
des nôtres mais qu'il me revient aussi
d'entraîner vers l'avenir
françois hollande a abaissé la fonction
présidentielle il faudra la restaurer
si le peuple français me fait confiance
j'aurai le devoir de respecter le
contrat nous et avec lui et de tenir ma
charge avec dignité
je mesure la gravité de la situation et
les attentes de nos compatriotes
je vais aller maintenant à leur
rencontre tout je vais relever avec eux
un défi aux offres
le défi de la vérité est celui d'un
changement complet de logiciels
alors je donne ce soir rendez vous à
tous ceux qui savent que le bonheur est
une conquête
je donne rendez vous à tous ceux qui ont
dans le coeur la fierté d'être français
mon ambition c'est de hisser la nation
vers le meilleur d'elle-même et je vous
le certifie si en 2017 nous prenons
fermement les choses en main alors notre
pays ira loin
parce que rien n'arrête un peuple qui se
dressent pour son avenir
chers amis mes chers compatriotes avec
ces primaires c'est une espérance qui
est né et bien ma mission c'est de la
faire grandir pour la france et pour la
république
à
non